welcome everyone
my name is david rivers i'm a professor
of biology at loyola university maryland
i'm trained as a forensic entomologist
and i have this unique trait of
studying flies during their times of
spinning and puking and i'm going to
spend time actually trying to present to
you
this afternoon about fly pattern
evidence in which
insects themselves actually create
contamination at crime scenes
and it's a relatively understudied area
that i think is fascinating and one that
actually needs more attention
so the plan is to introduce you to the
topic show you some pictures
do a little bit of show and tell and
give you a different perspective of
forensic entomology
in fact from that regard i am a forensic
entomologist
and i think that most people understand
that forensic entomology is usually
viewed from a positive standpoint for
criminal investigations
from the standpoint that um the most
common use of
of insects has been that their
development of bugs on bodies as i like
to say
can be useful for estimations of
portions of the postmortem interval
there are many examples in which that
has been useful for a death
investigation
and there certainly there are many other
uses for insects that are considered to
be aiding a criminal investigation
what has received much less intention
however is when insects actually
contaminate crime scenes and i'm talking
specifically about flies and adult flies
in particular
the reality is that when insects are
attracted to
a death scene it's because they're there
to dine
they they are interested in foraging
upon either the corpse or the body
fluids that have actually been
released particularly if we're talking
about a violent crime
and they're there to eat on any of those
types of fluids and to be honest they're
actually
they're very very sloppy and they can
actually do a number of things that are
actually not of benefit to the criminal
investigation
in fact i like to think about the
association between flies
and evidence at the scene as having the
potential where the flies can modify the
existing evidence that actually exists
so if we think about blood stains in
particular
then flies are already known to modify
the shapes of some of the blood stains
that are actually found at the crime
scene which is not aiding in the
reconstruction efforts
and in fact they can go so far as to
destroy the evidence as well
through their feeding activity this is
something that we certainly understand
that they do
when the adult fly feeds upon the corpse
and or deposits eggs or larvae they
start to consume the largest physical
piece of
of evidence that's actually associated
with a death investigation the corpse
itself
but they can consume entire stains at
the same time leaving
little or no evidence that of the stain
itself
but then to counter those two relatively
negative aspects
flies do have the ability to preserve it
some forms of evidence
at least for a temporary period of time
what i mean by that is
that the fly can actually feed upon a
body fluid and again let's say
blood and then when they do
they have a tendency after that they've
had it in their digestive system
for a period of time of either
regurgitating
or defecating and creating a new stain
that might be in some other location
from where the corpse was originally
and those stains will dry very very
quickly so in essence whatever was in
the stain
meaning the proteins in the dna and
sometimes drugs that
were in the tissues that they fed upon
are now locked in a dry state
and preserved that might be valuable
evidence at a later
time particularly if the crime scene's
already been cleaned up and someone
discovers later that there are actually
these fly stains that are actually
located somewhere else such as around a
window or on a lampshade or
some other artificial light source so we
have
different potential outcomes that can be
the result of adult flies
actually showing up to a crime scene and
we can see that the majority of the
examples i've given you so far
are the flies doing something
destructive that's not aiding in the
investigation
and that's going to be our primary focus
here that this is the the pattern
evidence that the flies are actually
creating
other insects do as well but flies tend
to be the most abundant
uh of the types of insects that will
actually show up under most situations
so they will be our primary focus
over the next few minutes when we're
talking about pattern evidence created
by insects
now again as we talk about what adult
flies can actually do
there tends to be two broad categories
that we think about
when we um associate
insects interacting or associating with
any type of stains
that might result from the deceased
individual
one is the modification that i've
already referred to and the reality is
flies will interact with wet or dry
stains
when they do however there are
differential
outcomes that come about and that will
be evident as we actually look at a few
examples in a few minutes
the other thing that can happen is that
the flies through their feeding activity
can create unique stains that can also
be
as they walk through wet blood and then
deposited um
some type of transfer pattern and they
come in more than one
uh form and again we'll take a look at
these in a moment
so that's more of the modification of
the saying it's also creating new stains
and through their their normal
activities of their digestive tract
again this idea that they actually will
consume the food and in some cases
actually
enter into bubbling behavior that we can
see in the upper right hand corner here
where a drop of blood is dangling from
their mouth parts when they drop that
stain at a crime scene
then they've created a new stain that
can have the appearance
in many ways to certain forms of blood
stains
and the same can happen when we're
talking about fecal elimination with
these flies because their feces is
liquid
and oftentimes that feces is going to
have the same color
as the food source that they've consumed
again we're referring to the body fluids
at the crime scene
and those stains may be confused at
times or very difficult to distinguish
between certain types of blood stains
and other body fluids depending upon the
context
now this type of association has long
been recognized by individuals
that are working crime scenes
particularly blood stain analysts
who've actually coined the term insect
stain
in reference to blood stains that are
created or resulting from
insect activity now this definition does
not actually specify any particular type
of insect
nor does it reference any specific type
of mechanism
so it's a very broad term from the
standpoint of forensic entomology
but in most cases we tend to be thinking
about flies or the culprits in this
particular case and we will
we'll see many examples this stain or
this
term also is very specific
from the standpoint it's only referring
to modification of blood stains
and we know that flies are very p are
not
particular in the food that they will
actually feed upon they're seeking foods
high in protein
and the reality is they will actually
feed on a multitude of other types of
materials
so not only will they create feed on a
multitude of materials
they will feed uh and and create
a wide range of other types of stains
that go well beyond just blood stains
in fact in many cases we depending upon
the fly species and the contacts we've
been able to identify
a large number of different types of
stains that are being created by
different mechanisms
we will look at many of these as we
proceed through this talk
this morning but at the same time there
will be some that will be
specific to certain circumstances that
are not going to be associated with
blood so
if it's not associated with blood we
really won't make it much of an emphasis
for right now but the point is there's a
lot more types of stains that are
actually produced than what most people
actually think and that's been reported
in the literature
and that has led to coining a broader
term than just insect stains so insect
artifacts
really kind of encapsulates this idea
that flies feed upon more than blood
they modify
more than just blood at a crime scene
and
there's a wide range of stains that are
actually being created
so by mechanisms that have not been
addressed necessarily
widely in the literature as well in fact
you can think of insect stains being
a subset of the term of insect artifacts
and i'll have a tendency to move back
and forth between these terms
since we are going to focus on blood
throughout this talk
then we really are talking about insect
stains by and large
but you're going to see that if you have
some familiarity with this topic
uh it's going to change your perspective
i think just a little bit
regardless of how that we want to define
it there are some some
basic characteristics that we can
actually talk about with insect
artifacts
one of those is that the bio the
morphology of the stain itself
tends to be a reflection of the surface
material which it's been deposited
and what that means broadly is that the
topography and the porosity of the
surface material is going to influence
the appearance of the stain but so will
the surface chemistry
and there will be unique interactions
that take place and i'll try to describe
those as we actually go
we will see that most evidently when we
are actually making a distinction
between stains that are deposited on
non-porous surfaces
versus those that are deposited on
textiles and fabrics
and in the grand scheme of things the
even the information that's associated
with
uh human blood stains on textiles and
fabrics is
minuscule by comparison to the
information that's out there on
non-porous surfaces
color of insect stains insect artifacts
i think that there's examples in the
literature that refers
to insect stains being relatively easy
to distinguish from human blood stains
based upon
color characteristics that is
a statement that can only be made within
context
because it is dependent upon not only
the surface material
and and the degree of contrast or the
background color of the material that's
been deposited
but there are most definitely species
differences that actually
exist as well and um and it would take
too long to try to give you every single
example
during this particular talk of the
variation we've looked at 37 different
species of flies
so we know there's a lot of variation
that actually exists
the there is literature that indicates
that you might be able to
have uh specific characteristics in
terms of alternate lighting
with various types of insect artifacts
fly artifacts in particular
that the literature is still in its
infancy um i
that there there has been some work
that's been done recently that
suggests you might be able to
distinguish any type of insect stain
from true blood stains but all that work
so far has been done in the laboratory
setting so
we will avoid going too far with it
other than to simply say
there's the possibility that you can use
alternate lighting
because digestive artifacts those that
are created from the digestive tract of
the fly
tend to be unique from the other types
of artifacts
that that we can look at
so with that in mind we're getting
geared up so that we can
start doing some show and tell so that i
can introduce the types of stains to you
what i want to do first though is just
give you just a brief synopsis
of all the stains that we have observed
at this point that could potentially be
produced by flies
there are four that stand out as the
most common
that you would encounter when um when
the fly has associated with blood
those four wind up being regurgitated
stains defecatory stains translocation
tarsal tracts the first two regurgitate
and defecatory
i commonly refer to as digestive stains
they're produced from either end of the
digestive tract they are
the by far the most common ones that we
would actually see at the crime scene
and um they have unique morphologies and
they have unique mechanisms that lead to
that the
latter two are far less common but under
certain conditions and with certain
flies we tend to see translocation
more frequently than we do in other
situations tarsal tracks for example
are what we refer to as fly footprints
the fly has walked through blood
and or it's walked over the top of blood
and actually then transfers
footprints fly footprints to a
non-bloodied surface
are very common with smaller bodied
flies particularly in the genus
chrysomia
and in lucilia much less common when
we're actually talking about a flush
flying sarcophagi
or some of the larger bodies blow flies
such as cinema or some of the larger
california
or cal colifero species in particular
in terms of how are these stains
produced
regurgitation is actually
the result of expulsion of food material
that's actually in the foregut of the
adult flies
uh digestive tract so this means from
the crop forward that food is actually
driven forward to
through the mouth parts and usually it
is dangling from the tip of the mouth
and is most commonly observed as
bubbling behavior and there's a number
of
working ideas behind why do flies
actually bubble
what we do know is that most species
that would be associated with the crime
scene will
drop that that bubble or the regurgitate
at the crime scene either intermixed
with other stains or in unique locations
and um the full intent is for the adult
side to come back later and feed
upon it in fact our our observations
suggest that
flies are far more interested in feeding
upon regurgitate that contains blood
than actually feeding upon human blood
itself
this this regurgitate is not to be
confused with vomiting or vomitus which
was actually reported
in some of the early literature in the
1970s and 1980s
vomiting is an entirely different
mechanism that takes place with adult
flies
and actually the the contents are
actually derived from the mid gut not
from the foregut
now this may not seem like of importance
to
a crime scene investigation but it is
from the standpoint that
the vomitus is actually chemically
distinct from regurgitate
and it also has a different morphology
as well flies have a tendency not to
engage in vomiting on a frequent basis
so you're not expecting that
that vomit would actually be associated
um or any type of vomit stains with the
crime scene under normal situations
the other stain that's very very common
are
the result of fecal elimination
defecation which would seem like it
should be just a very straightforward to
say this is how
the flies actually defecate but there's
really not much that is normal nor
simple
when we're talking about forensic
insects and in the case of flies they
have at least three mechanisms that they
actually use
for eliminating feces one is that the
fly is stationary
and it's the body is positioned more or
less parallel to the substrate that it's
resting upon
so that when it forces waste material
out of the anus in this case
the drop actually will will be pushed
out passively
and it falls more or less perpendicular
to the surface of which it's deposited
and also a very short distance the the
net effect is that this
the resulting stain will generally be
round or circular in
appearance with no stains and no
evidence of edges such as
spikes or scallops that you might see
with certain types of blood stains that
have fallen perpendicular
in contrast if that if the fly is
actually stationary but then begins to
move
meaning to walk to run or even to fly
before that is completed
fecal elimination there will be a tail
that will be associated with that
fecal stain that will taper in the
direction that the fly was actually
moving
in some cases that tail will be very
long that suggests that the fly was
walking in other cases if the fly is
running sometimes it's tapping its
abdomen as it's doing so
creating almost a dotted line appearance
to the stain itself
and then finally the third mechanism
that they can use is that some flies
not all that we've actually observed
have the ability to protrude the anus
and forcibly expel liquid feces
parallel to the surface at which it's
resting upon
in which case that the feces is airborne
and has been
pushed out of the anus under high
pressure
so that the characteristics of that
airborne liquid are somewhat similar to
certain forms of blood spatter
so when that the feces actually then
makes contact with the surface
the the drop will still continue to move
creating a tail that's pointing in the
direction that the
fecal elimination it was actually
um moving at that particular time so we
can have
tails that represent different patterns
of movement um
that actually exists as well like i say
it's nothing isn't necessarily
straightforward when we're actually
talking about the flies all right so
i've given you an idea that we
we have more than just insect stains
that might be associated with
um any type of body fluid but blood in
particular and now we have a rough idea
of some of the mechanisms that lead to
these stains
let's do the show-and-tell piece where i
start showing you some of these things
so
what you're about to see first would be
fly stains that
have been created through interactions
with wet blood
the stains themselves are being
deposited first on
non-porous surfaces just to give you
full context
what we're looking at here then is a
relatively representative
image of what we would see for
regurgitate so that we see in the center
this large
mostly round circular stain with
others that are smaller much smaller but
similar color appearance these are
various sizes that regurgitate can come
in
this is from the same the same species
of flies not the same individual but the
same species of flies we're looking at
all the scenes we'll be looking at for
the most part
are from clifford basina a a california
common fly particularly for talking
north america very common if we're
talking about cooler temperatures of
spring
or fall very common throughout europe as
well so this is
one that will produce larger stains
than some of the ones that we would see
during peak time during the summer
months itself
next to it is actually a regurgitated
stain that contains no blood
in it whatsoever so giving you more of
this tan to golden appearance then
um is important context when it actually
can be used as indication that there was
fly activity
or a fly has actually fed upon the stain
as opposed to mechanically damaging that
stain itself
in contrast we can get defecatory stains
like we see in this particular case that
are produced from the passive drop low
pressure mechanisms
more or less circular defecatory things
show
a wider variation in color uh depending
upon the species that we're looking at
from light to very
dark with also having the appearance of
the food source that was actually
consumed
as well and this gives you context next
to that in many cases deficatory stains
can be much bigger than regurgitate
but there are other times that that's
not the case at all
uh if the deficatory stain is produced
when the fly is actually in motion as we
actually see in this particular case you
wind up getting a stain with the tail
that has a tadpole or a sperm
cell shape with the tapering pointing to
the left indicating that's the direction
of fly movement
in contrast to that you can have it
where that the fly
has created a defecatory stain that does
have a small tail that
that's much less in terms of the length
by comparison to the diameter of the
stain itself and in this case
this was a stain that was produced from
the fly actually beginning to flight
before that it was actually done
defecating hence the smaller
the smaller tail that we actually see
and there's all kinds of
degradations that can be in between
and there are some species that don't
ever seem to produce deficatory stains
that have a tail
at all making it much more challenging
particularly when those stains
have the same morphology as
as the food source that they fed upon
blood in that particular case
translocation or transfer patterns are
most typically going to take place with
the flies
when they have walked through
wet blood and then in this particular
case drug
a portion of the leg or the the other
most common is when they drag the
abdomen
actually through the blood creating
these more or less long lines that are
that may or may not be completely
symmetrical or straight
above that what you can actually see are
these fainter lines
which were that the same leg was used
repeatedly to drag but
there's less and less blood um still
remaining on the leg to be
transferred to a non-bloody surface
the fourth major type that we come
across winds up being tarsal tracks
which are created when the fly walks
through the blood or walks over the top
of the blood
and then deposits footprints in many
locations now there is
at least one paper that indicates that
in their observations the flies did not
have sufficient mass to break the
surface tension
of the blood drop um but i've worked
with the same species and
have have observed just the opposite i
think it's more of a reflection
that the the drying state of the blood
stain
is probably the bigger factor not the
mass of the fly
uh we do see that tarsal tracks are more
likely to be
very common at a crime scene when you're
dealing with small flies
in the genus chrysomia lucilia and to a
lesser extent formia
and seem to be much less common when
we're dealing with large bodied flies
such as clifford vasina clifford
vomitoria cinema cadaver rena
sarcophagus so um
the tendency that we've seen so far more
testing needs to be done to make sure if
that's an absolute
observation or not uh just to give you
complete contrast
um so you're looking at stains that were
created
with a um a water-based solution
we did this merely for the video taping
that we were doing we've seen this with
blood as well
but we're trying to decrease the
contamination of our
our behavior observation uh arena that
we're using
uh two patterns that were quite
surprising to us when we actually
observed these the first time
one i refer to as purge where that adult
flies
actually had recently consumed large
volumes of blood
and then were repeatedly disturbed by
other flies
that led to them essentially dropping
their payload from the crop
or purging the entire contents so that
they immediately took flight
whether i would go so far as to say
that's a defensive response i don't know
but these stains tend to be quite large
in diameter they tend to exceed four
millimeters which is not common um
and again they seem to be largely a
reflection
of purging the entire contents
when you actually test them with
presumptive testing or
with confirmatory testing they
demonstrate all the characteristics of
human blood
so it's a large volume in that case cast
off
actually is created under different
scenarios but the most common and
actually
the one that covered this piece of paper
that we're actually looking at where
when there was pooled blood and the
flies actually landed in it in such a
way that they
they got wet blood on their wings
flies do not like to be dirty and they
started to
flip their wings and casting off the
blood that was on the outside of the
wings
that within a 10-second period of time
completely started to cover this entire
surface so
if they cast off appearance that we see
on a vertical surface in this particular
case but they do this
um when the wings wind up having blood
on it they can also fling blood off of
the body using their leg
legs as well because the body's
hydrophobic and
there can be droplets of blood that
cling under the wings or on various
surfaces that the fly actually flings
off
creating a cast off appearance as well
now if the surface actually changes so
that we're now looking
at a porous material then the
characteristics of the stains change
radically so what we're looking at in
this particular case are
stains have been produced on a new
cotton t-shirt that has not been washed
if i had not been observing the flies it
would be
nearly impossible if not impossible to
distinguish between regurgitate and
defecatory stains
usually tails are not evident in many
cases but what is significant here is
that we actually
started detecting a new form of
defecatory stain
what i reference as fecal spheres that
actually have
almost a person perfect sphere
three-dimensional appearance to it
there is virtually no absorption and
wicking that takes place into the yarns
of this fabric whatsoever
and these are deficatory stains that
were produced
by the forcible elimination from a
protruded anus
this suggests that chemically that fecal
spheres are
distinct from defecatory stains we have
not done the chemical analysis to
demonstrate that
but it is significant and keep in mind
this is a new cotton t-shirt
because by comparison to a a t-shirt
that has been washed over 30 times
we see that absorption and a small
amount of wicking is much more common
with these stains
and just very few in the upper right
hand corner there's
two of these fecal spheres by comparison
to significantly more
when it's an unwashed material and we
see that actually with a number of
fabrics including denim
with various types of carpet as well and
and there's still other materials to be
tested
uh in this example this is dry dry wick
polyester that has not been
washed and we tried to simulate the wear
conditions of
shirts so the loose would be someone
wearing a baggy shirt versus flat which
is
untucked but a regular fit versus tight
a tucked shirt in that particular case
so what you'll notice is
this was material designed for wicking
and you see substantial
increases in wicking of the digestive
artifacts
when there's tension on the fabric in
fact a close-up view of that
shows you that the parent stain is much
darker and can be seen
in the center and a secondary stain is
the wicking
and this is a relatively low volume most
of the flies
will deposit anywhere between 0.1
microliters to
1 to 2 microliters of liquid in
regurgitative or deficit
but there's substantial wicking where
that the total stain
may represent close to 10 millimeters um
blood behaves in a very similar fashion
so this is something that
where that the stain appearance and the
wicking characteristics are
very very similar with blood that makes
it very difficult to distinguish between
them
in contrast on drywick polyester
flies that actually are creating tarsal
tracks have a very unique appearance
and that there's little wicking and in
fact it looks like that we have these uh
these short linear lines from blood
that's on the surface of
the knit loops in this particular case
most frequently being on
the the loop legs there doesn't seem to
be any difference between the left or
the right loop
leg but they're the the mater the blood
is mostly at a
superficial or our surface level
now and for some species we can get
sharp contrast and you so that we can
really see the uniqueness in the stains
themselves
so what you're seeing here is not from
clifford of the senate this is actually
more typical of two flies that we've
looked at
sarcophagi's sarcophagus of gulata and
cinema
cadaverenna are the two that really
showed distinct colored stains
the yellows the greens uh the grays the
browns
and you also get a sense of that dotted
line appearance that was created from
the fly running as it was actually
defecating at the same time
in this scenario there would be
absolutely no difficulty being able to
distinguish between what is a true blood
stain
and what is a a fly stain but that's not
the norm
for most of the species that we've
actually looked at
when we've had a situation where we've
used new plush carpet
then if i didn't know that these were
fly stains i don't even know that i
would suspect that because it doesn't
look like blood
and this is still carpet that most
likely has this stain blocker actually
on it it hasn't been swept it hasn't
been washed
and so we see that there's very little
absorption and no wicking to speak of
that has taken place
we can't distinguish what type of fly
artifact and again i'm not sure that you
would distinguish that it is a fly
artifact in that case
it's kind of a similar appearance this
is washed denim
similar appearance whether we use washed
or unwashed denim in this particular
case that the stains are deposited
mostly at a surface level
with very little absorption very little
wicking
very common for this type of material
many more that we've actually looked at
but we don't have the time to look at
all of those
what happens when the fly interacts with
dried blood
as opposed to wet blood like what we've
just looked at well the
morphology is much much different
so for example the stains that we're
looking at are on ceramic tile so our
non-porous surface
in many cases the stain can be modified
flaking has taken place here from
mechanical interaction the flies have
run over it
they've walked over it and if you have
loose
flaking that's taking place and they
flap their wings they can blow that that
blood stain
or portions of the stain a good distance
away
when they feed upon it then you can
create perimeter
stains and what you wind up saying is
that they're feeding upon the center
we know that this wasn't due to flanking
because we have dried regurgitate that's
actually evident right here
in this particular case it's clear and
we have developed an immunoassay that
allows us to distinguish that this was
definitely due to fly activity
from feeding so that we can confirm that
similarly you have the formation of a
perimeter stain but in this case there
was such a large volume volume of
recursive that was deposited
that it wound up having some diffusion
of the blood into the recurrence it's
staining the regurgitate even though it
was not actually
um it was actually the same color that i
just showed you on the ceramic tile
flies can create skeletal stains so that
you just have fragments left over so
this is further
consumption and then some cases you can
also have skeletal stains
that are completely enveloped in the
regurgitate like what we saw with the
perimeter stain
as well as having some of the diffusion
of blood into that dried recursive
still with the skeletal stain itself if
you compare that
to dried stains on
porous materials again we're looking at
a new cotton t-shirt the flies show
no interest this is after 24 hours
exposed to
several adult flies we see minimally
just a just
one piece of evidence of flaking taking
place and no modification of the same
that is very characteristic of what we
see with stains on porous surfaces
whether we use denim like that we're
seeing here whether that we use
carpet whether that we use any type of
shirt or other types of clothing apparel
flies generally show very little
interest in dried stains
on porous materials itself i believe
it's
a tactile issue and the the mouth parts
are sensitive
that any of the fabrics and that the
upper topography actually
is perceived as as being something they
don't want to associate with
they will also deposit stains on a
corpse and so
i have not had access to human corpse
i've seen pictures that have
many uh fly artifacts on them in this
particular case replicating that
piglets that we've used in outdoor
decomposition we see that we have
many artifacts being deposited on the
the skin and on the hair the same is
true with guinea pigs and indoor
decomposition
the tendency in this case particularly
if we're talking the colder months
in the spring or in the fall the flies
tend to go for the head first
eventually you will see that the body is
totally covered in the warmer months we
tend to see that there's
very little preference to where that the
artifacts are deposited but
they are also being deposited on the
corpse whether the skin is
fully exposed or whether that the
individual is
clothed or partially closed
what does all this mean to us well what
what we have found from our initial
examination of these
these fly patterns is that there's not
nearly as much known about them as we
need to know
and i believe they're also undervalued
as well can they serve as
valuable pieces of information or
reconstruction the answer is possibly
because we also know that there are
other features such as time of day when
they show preferences for laying this
specific locations on the body so there
might be some time maps that we can
derive from understanding
the artifacts more study is needed we
know that the morphologies are much more
complicated than most textbooks have
referenced
um and there's has been almost no
previous work on porous materials until
very recently and that's mostly out of
my research lab so our complete
understanding of the difference of these
types of
patterns on porous versus non-porous is
superficial at best
and we need to know more we also need to
develop
much more effective methods for
differentiating between blood stain
evidence and fly evidence
and and i can tell you that on porous
materials it's virtually impossible to
distinguish the two
does it matter everyone's going to have
a different opinion about that last
statement but
i can tell you that when you put this in
the context that
fly stains are potential sources of
secondary dna transfer
both to and from the crime scene and
that the flies themselves can retain a
blood mill for
up to three weeks and still be
depositing artifacts that contain both
dna
and protein and that test positive by
any of your chemical tests
yes there is very much a need to
investigate this further
so that we understand and can recognize
these types of stains
much more effectively that we can now
this was only a just a brief
introduction that it's an entirely
different story to talk about
all the methods available for
distinguishing these artifacts
so i appreciate your attention and i'm
happy to answer any questions so feel
free to reach out to me if you have any
you want to know more
i'd love to talk to you but that is the
presentation
and i appreciate your attendance thank
you very much